- Social media is filled with
all sorts of cool things.
I enjoy bringing you my favorites.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Makeup tutorials have been a hot trend
on social media for a bit,
but one Connecticut woman
isn't just sharing her makeup tips.
She actually throws down
some serious relationship
advice at the same time
which has earned her nearly 1
million followers on TikTok.
- I talk about the 20
lessons on love and life
that I had to learn the hard way.
Just because a man loves you
doesn't mean he wants
to be with you forever.
Sometimes the person you want
is not the person you need to be with.
If you need to make excuses
for why you should stay in a relationship,
it probably means you need to leave.
You can be the best version of yourself
and still get rejected, and that's 'cause
not everyone appreciates
the same type of art.
Always choose the man who
makes you feel at peace
rather than the man who makes you feel
like you're on a rollercoaster.
The rollercoaster is exciting,
but at some point you need to get off.
If someone is telling you to settle,
it probably means they didn't get
what they wanted in life and
don't wanna see you get yours.
(audience claps and cheers)
- I love her. (chuckles)
And Anna says she's got the experience
to back up her words of wisdom.
We've got her on the line
now watching on NBC New York.
What's going on Anna?
(audience claps and cheers)
- Hi, great to see you.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, first of all, you're hilarious.
Secondly, you are stunningly beautiful.
So how did you come up with
this creative combination
of beauty and romance?
- Well, growing up in Pennsylvania
in the 90s as an Asian American girl,
there weren't a lot of makeup artists
who knew how to do my face.
So I taught myself how to do my own makeup
through a lot of trial and error.
And of course the other
component to my stories
is my very checkered dating history.
I probably went on at
least 200 first dates
in my twenties in New York
and have a lot of failed relationships
and a lot of stories as a result.
And I put the two together,
not really thinking anything of it.
Posted my first get ready with me
on September 1st of this last year.
It went viral and I've done at least
50 get ready with me's since then.
- Oh my gosh.
Your advice is hilarious
and also very true.
So what's your best advice
and what's your relationship status now?
- I am married to my best friend
and I would've never met him-
- Congratulations.
- [Anna] If it wasn't for
all the failed relationships.
- Yeah.
- I truly believe that failure
is such a critical component to growth.
And I always tell people
that there is always a light
at the end of the tunnel if
we bring our own lighter.
I think what I learned from my twenties
is that when you're young
and your life is blowing up in your face
and nothing's going according to plan,
everything feels like
the end of the world.
But it's not, it is just the beginning.
- Yeah, it's just a moment.
You're right. You're right.
Well, thank you so much
and I'm liking your post
right now, all right.
(heart tings)
(audience claps and cheers)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the
"Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to celebrate truly unstoppable
and funny people just like you.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience claps and cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna go buy a lot of
ice-cream now. (laughs)
- Thank you Anna.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Brooke Shields, Echo Kellum, Chef Blondie,
Dr. Lauren Cohen and Mario Lopez.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.